good afternoon everyone hello strange
loop my name is Nadia Polycarp Ola I'm
an assistant professor at the University
of California in San Diego and I'm
really excited to be here and tell you a
little bit about the research that I've
been doing with my students and
collaborators the goal of our research
is to automate programming just like in
the car industry by increasing
automation over the years we were able
to produce cars faster and more reliably
in the software industry by increasing
the level of automation in our
programming languages we are able to
build software at a lower cost and with
fewer errors and let's get this out of
the way before we get really mad at me
I'm not trying to put the programmers
are jobs instead it's quite a contrary
actually I want programmers to be able
to focus on the interesting parts of
their job as opposed to getting buried
in all the low-level details so let me
illustrate this idea with a very simple
example suppose I want to write a
program that inserts a value into a
sorted list at an appropriate position
more precisely my program takes as input
a value let's call it X and the list
let's call it X's and returns a list
wise that is sorted and has all elements
of XS prospects ok so I can implement
this program in a functional language as
a simple recursive function let's call
it insert that takes two arguments X and
XS and the first thing it does is it
pattern matches all the input list XS to
figure out whether it's an empty list
we call it nil or whether it's non-empty
whether it has a head
and age and the palest T in the first
case we can simply return a singleton
list that contains X and in the second
case we have to compare the new element
X with a head of the list and if X is
less than equal than the head then we
have found the right position and we can
simply prepare X 2 X s and otherwise we
will have to call insert recursively on
the tail alright that wasn't too bad
there was a little simple 8 line program
but if I wanted to write the same
program in C I would have to do a lot
more work right and why is that that's
because unlike C Pascal automates a lot
of stuff for me and yeah I called it
Haskell even though it's not really half
the language that I'm going to use
throughout my talk it's like a simple
very minimalistic functional language
where the Haskell like syntax but with a
couple of differences hopefully there
will be self-explanatory um so this
functional language let's call Haskell
automates a bunch of stuff for me things
like pointer manipulation and memory
management and things like that
so if I wanted to write this program in
assembly I would have to do even more
work because even C automates a bunch of
stuff for me things like passing
arguments and values between you know
functions accessing memory and things
like that so as you can see from this
diagram over the past couple decades
programming languages have made a lot of
progress right things are way way more
automated now than before but at this
point let's ask ourselves is this it is
Haskell in fact the pinnacle of creation
um in this talk I will share with you my
vision about what this question mark
might stand for so what might be the
next cool thing that's coming up in
programming languages in more detail I
will argue that the new cool feature of
programming languages is programming
with specifications and the program
synthesis technology is what can make it
real is what can make it happen
and finally in the last part of my talk
I will talk about how this protein
synthesis technology might integrate
with our programming languages to
provide this new programming paradigm
that I call synthesis aided programming
so let's start with the specifications
so what I mean by that is how do we
actually express our intent to the
Machine how do we explain to the Machine
what I want my program to do so remember
when I wrote this functional program for
insert I still had to do like three
different cases depending on you know
what the input list is and what the how
it relates to value I don't want to
explain any of that so this was like too
much hand-holding for me all I want to
say in my description of insert is that
it's a function that takes as input a
value X and X if it's a sorted list and
it returns a sorted list that contains
all the element of X's and X so this
kind of specification is much more high
level than the program that I wrote
before it's much easier for me to get
right but unfortunately it's very hard
for the computer to execute and here's
where program synthesis comes in to
automatically translate such a
specification into efficiently
executable code such as for example the
recursive program that we had before in
this talk I will
show you how secret has frugal
synthesizer that I have developed can
deal with this exact problem but before
I can show you how Berlin since this
works let's discuss how do we actually
express the specification so we need to
come up with some notation for writing
down our specifications that is formal
enough for the machine to understand it
and yet high-level than that so we don't
go back to you know just writing
programs right so what can this notation
be for expressing high-level intent
about programs well it turns out that
programmers and especially functional
programmers have kind of figured it out
already and we routinely use types to
express high-level intent about programs
so we might use types to just document
what an existing piece of code is doing
or after example if you program in
Haskell you're probably used to tool
called who go where you can search for
API functions by their type so okay
let's start with that let's use types
and let's write down sort of a Haskell
style a type for insert so this type
here says that insert takes a value of
any type a and takes a list of a's and
produces OS of a's if you are actually a
Haskell programmer you with you
something is missing from this type in
particular we want to be able to compare
the elements of the list so we kind of
forgot to write down this constraint
that our type a has to be ordered but
let's just ignore this to the end if you
talk and assume that all type variables
are always ordered so this type
signature already tells us a lot about
the version actually it tells us the
function that it takes two arguments you
know it filters out a lot of sort of the
functions that we don't want right but
it doesn't really say everything that we
want to say about this function right
and in fact as an experiment let's try
to give this type as an input to the
sync with synthesizer and see what
function
gonna get back I'm showing you the web
interface for sync with can you all see
the code I can okay so what I wrote
here is just the same type signature
that we had before and now I'm asking
sync way to synthesize this function
right by putting this question mark over
here and unfortunately it doesn't all
fit on the slide but if you run this
then what you get is a function that
just returns its second argument right
because obviously we gave you the list
of ways and you know it just gives us
the same ways back nothing wrong with
that because we in fact didn't tell it
that this list has to have some special
set of elements right and as you can see
here compared to the Husker signature
that I showed you in sync with you're
able to name the arguments or the
function inside the type just so that
you get like sort of a nice sort of
function back all right
so how do we how do we add more
information to our type to in fact
express those additional properties that
would care about such as well we we know
that the input list is sorted but we
also want to guarantee that the output
list is both sorted and has all the
elements of X's and X right how do we
put this information in the type so
lucky for us the programming language
community have come up with a lot of
different interesting type systems that
allow you to express advanced properties
about your programs right and one of
those is called reformer types so the
idea behind refinement types is that you
can decorate your sort of regular
Haskell types like type in here with
this little simple predicate that
further restrict the range of the types
so for example I can write down the type
of natural numbers like this by saying
that natural numbers are such values new
of type and that are greater than equal
to zero
and so this sort of the the high school
type part of this is called the shape of
the refinement type and this part is
called their farm okay I mean this
doesn't sound very impressive you know
it seems like all I can do with it it's
like express some ranges of integers
what does it have to do with you know
talking about sorted lists and their
elements well it turns out that if you
combine the simple requirements with
other cool features of functional
languages like algebraic data types and
pulley morphism really cool stuff starts
to come out so let me illustrate this
with you know let's not define a data
type for sorted lists using your finance
we'll start from the data type for a
regular list just for those of you who
have never you know defined an algebraic
data type before and that's okay so we
can define lists as so they're like two
types of Lists right so a list can be
empty or it can consist of a head
element age or and the tail list T right
so there it is two constructors nil and
constable of the following types okay so
how do we now express that this list is
sorted so let's define and you lay the
type that will we're gonna call F list
for sorted lists right and how do we
modify this definition to make this
lists always sorted right so well the
new case it's actually fine because an
empty list is always sorted so we can
just say nil is a sorted list but what
about cons right if we just change all
the types inside the cons to sorted list
it's not quite right right because we're
saying I take any element age and any
sorted list T and I put them together
and I get a sorted list which is not
true because you know age might be
actually greater than the next element
then like the first element some teeth
but remember this type is polymorphic in
a or generic if you're used to Java
right so in fact this type of the
element is a
you can substitute whatever you want for
for the element type of the tale and in
fact we can put a refine attack there
you see where I'm going
we can say that the tale list is a list
of such ace that are greater equal than
H and now actually got a sorted list
because if we take a list where the tail
is sorted and every element in the tail
is greater equal than the head then we
know that the resulting list is going to
be sorted okay
so my point here was that we need just
one very simple small requirement to
define something that's non trivial as
sorted list so now that we have sorted
lists we are sort of well equipped to
define you know the type of insert that
we can actually feed as an input to the
synthesizer right so we can say that you
know insert takes an X sorry it says
instead of a apologies about that and
that XS is a sorted list and it returns
a sorted list this S list that we have
just defined and we can further refine
the resulting type to say that other
elements of the result are the elements
of X's and X and this elements function
you can think of it as just sort of a
recursive function on lists that
translates a list intercept and sync
reports there's special kind of
functions that you can use in
specifications that I'll also mention
later so let's see what happens if you
give this as an input to sync with so
let's modify our signature so it's going
to be an S list and well let's first
give it a name and we can say that this
is elements of XS plus X but in fact in
sync wait there's sort of a a special
keyword for naming this this variable of
the refinement
we don't even have to define it right so
it's always called underscore B so if we
give sync with this type then you can
see that you know in Wheeling a fraction
of a second it generates exactly the
function that we want it to so that was
cool how do you do that
so in the second part of the talk I'll
talk about some senses the technology
behind this right so the prop so how do
we get from this specification to code
right so our problem is given this
refinement type automatically generate
some function that has a side right and
so what is this magic machine that does
this transformation well in fact it's
it's the main idea of bringing synthesis
it's very very simple modern program
synthesis approaches treat synthesis as
a search problem which essentially means
that so we're given this specification
in this case or the primer type and we
pick a set of components sort of
building blocks or library functions you
can think about them this way that the
synthesizer is allowed to use to
construct the program right in this case
the components that we need our tools
constructors and comparison and the
synthesizer will actually just try to
construct all kinds of programs that it
can't build out of those components and
try to type check each one of those
programs against the specification until
we find one the tactics well there's a
caveat here and you probably have
spotted it there like a lot of programs
then you can make from even like very
few components in fact if we take a
minimal set of components that we need
to build insert function and we only
consider all the functions of size less
or equal to our solution right which is
roughly the size of our search space
they're like two to the seventy function
that satisfies this constraint so if you
don't know what this number two to the
seventeen is like well yeah it's roughly
the number of you know stars in the
visible universe um so yeah how do we
find this one star that we're looking
for in this whole universe well so
obviously the secret is so we need to do
something smart right with a search and
the secret is is we should try to
eliminate sort of the irrelevant parts
of the space and like gradually so the
parts where we know for sure that our
program cannot be there right so that we
gradually sort of hold in on this
solution and secret does that actually
using it's a very clever type checker
and so the key idea is we will use this
clever type checking mechanism to reject
hopeless programs early so let me tell
you I'll let me explain what I mean by
that so sort of the naive way of doing
this would be you construct the whole
you know in constructive program
candidate from beginning to end and then
you run your type checker and then you
discover at the end that oh this wasn't
you know the right program so we're not
going to do that we are going to titrate
the program as we go as we are
constructing it right so we're gonna
type check is incomplete program
candidates and we're gonna try to detect
the type error as early as possible what
does this buy us well I mean if we can
determine that this program prefix is in
fact wrong and
be completed to get something meaningful
out of it right then we have
automatically rejected a whole bunch of
programs that start from the same prefix
and we could do that without ever
considering them and without ever
touching them so that sounds like a
really good yeah so let me illustrate
this again on an example so here's the
type of insert that we have before and
let's say our program we're constructing
this program candidate right it's going
to be wrong a spoiler alert so this
function insert is going to match on
axis which is was supposed to do but
then in the first case in the nil case
is going to return milk and that's wrong
because we know that in the first case
it's actually supposed to return a
singleton list that contains X and not
now right and in fact if we are able to
detect that if you're able to reject
this hopeless program then we have just
eliminated around 2 to the 50 programs
from our search space because there are
this many in our search space that begin
with this prefix so how think we'd do
that well it has this type checker that
well it start it can you know touch it
this incomplete program and how it's
going to do that but the type checkers
function against this function type it
has to type check the body of the
function against for the result type now
it's going to focus on the first branch
of this pattern match the empty branch
right where it has some additional
information it knows that the elements
of XS in this case are empty right so it
sort of specializes the specification
and it knows that what it needs to prove
in this case is that the snail has a
type it's a sorted list that is whose
only element is X right but I think we'd
knows in fact from the type of the new
constructor that or rather from the
definition of this elms function is that
that the element of male are just empty
right so you can compare these two types
and in fact it will produce type error
that says well I expected a type
you know sorted list they don't have X
and what I got is a type sorted list
that don't have any elements and this is
a type mismatch you know type error okay
so it has this as I said it's a very
clever type checker that's built on top
of a lot of amazing technology from the
programming languages community like
bi-directional type checking liquid type
inference some cheese solvers you know
pretty good abstraction things like that
so if you know about any of the things
you know that will tell you something
and otherwise don't worry about this we
don't have time to go into details about
you know how this patrocle works I just
wanted to give you an intuition about
what it does and this is sort of a
simple case of how can reject hopeless
programs early there are sort of more
tricky cases too but the main point was
that this type checker that has this
property is basically the main the key
idea behind synced and using that so I
built this proof synthesizer that takes
us input a specification written as a
final type it takes as input a set of
components which are also expressed as
very apparent types and it produces this
code that probably satisfies the
specification so what you get is not
only a program but also a guarantee that
it will always produce the output that
you know satisfies the specification all
right so what we can think we do I mean
we're in it in a whole bunch of like
list algorithms sorting binary search
tree modifications you know balance tree
operations some custom data types so
this well but graphs are boring so let
me show you a complete example of
something like a little bit more
non-trivial that think it can do so one
of those points towards the end of this
graph is what's called negation normal
for transformation on propositional
formulas and by the way what this graph
is showing you is that we can synthesize
all those within like 70 seconds so it's
not you know it doesn't take very long
okay so let's look at this you know
slightly less trivial example
and then insert and it's this negation
normal form so if you don't know what it
is I'm going to quickly first tell you
what it is basically if you have a
propositional formula which is just a
fancy word for like a boolean expression
with boolean variables and like logical
connectors like disjunction and
conjunction and implication indication
then this formula is in negation normal
form if it satisfies two properties
first of all the only connectives that
it's allowed to have are negation
conjunction and disjunction so there
cannot be any implication in it for
example and the second property is that
you can only apply in Gatien to
variables so you cannot have nots and
then some conjunction like in this
formula so so this formula is like not
in negation on the form in two ways
right and it turns out that you know
every formula can be actually
transformed into an equivalent one in
negation normal form and you can you
know write a little program that does
that if you know various you know laws
of boolean algebra like the definition
of implication in terms of north and or
and the morgan laws and double negation
elimination and so on and then you will
finally arrive to this negation on the
form but if you don't know their flaws
then you can also use secret to do this
for you
so how do I kill this problem in sync
with step one we need to define some
data types but we would have to do that
even if we were to write this put it on
by hand right so we need to define what
our formulas are and what some negation
or form so we'll first define a data
type for formulas
well formulas can be variables that take
a string
you know variable name is a string they
can be negation of another formula and
all these binary operations like end or
it implies write that take two formulas
and return the formula so now we're
going to define what negation normal
form so what what is the formula in the
gauge normal form so if you were to
write this program by hand you perhaps
wouldn't define another data type for it
but in sync wait it's the most natural
thing is to just define nnf as a
separate data type so that only in NF
formulas are expressible as instances of
this data type and in fact that's very
easy to do you don't even need your
finals like at all
to do that right so how we're going to
restrict formulas to N and F well
instead of having like variable and
negation as two separate constructors
that would that allows you to put
arbitrary things inside negation we'll
just like blend them into one
constructor that we're going to call
atom that takes the variable name string
and it takes a boolean that stands for
is this variable negated right so now we
can express you know X as you know this
atom the false and we can express not
access this Apple literature and then we
of course we don't have negation we have
and an or and we don't have implication
right so this is what a formula in
negation normal form is so we define
this two data types okay now we can
write you know a function type that says
well given a formula I give me an N an F
right but that's not really all they
want to say because we also want to say
that this whole foremost should be
equivalent what does it mean
crewel means that this two formulas
should evaluate to say
value independently of what values we
assigned to the variables foremost so
how do we express that the Segway well
we will define a very simple evaluator
for each types of formulas and then we
will sort of relate those in the
refinement so how do we do this we will
define one of those measure functions so
you have seen the ellen's before so and
and it's called a measure it's just for
historical reasons so think of it as
like function to be used in refinements
as opposed to function that you can run
in your code and it has some syntactic
restrictions that we need in order for
this whole type checking machinery to
work out so we can define you know what
does it mean to evaluate each formula to
a boolean truth value right so okay the
first case that I need to define is
variable you know how to evaluate
variable well this kind of problematic
because the variable only has a value in
like a certain environment and we don't
have any like environment lying around
well the trick is because it's not a
real function that we're going to run
it's just a function that we're going to
use in the specification we can let
pretend that we have this global
variable and for global function rather
and that's for the values of all the
variables and we don't care what it is
we only care if it's a function right so
that's called an unattributed function
and our logic of requirements supports
such things so you're basically saying
yeah we're taking the value from the
square of this variable from this
mapping and that is something but we
don't care and we don't know anything
else about it and then we define all the
other cases you know very
straightforwardly to evaluate not we
have to evaluate the function and then
technician of it and so on for
conjunction disjunction implication and
then we define exactly you know very
similar function for the nnf type so
again a measure that map's in an F to a
boolean so for an Adam we have to check
if it's negated or not and depending on
that return either the value of the
variable or its negation and and an or
are exactly the same as before so now
with these types and measures we can in
fact just
hi the nnf function we could specify the
internet function like this we can say
that it takes a formula and it returns
an N and F that evaluates to the same
value as the original formula right and
because we don't know anything about
this end what the values of the
variables are this is like saying it
should have evaluate to the same value
no matter what the value so variables
are and if we give this a sync with you
know this kind of big function comes out
this particular one does one more
transformation than what I told you
about before it also just sugars boolean
literals but let's not focus on that so
the interesting parts about the follower
is that sync with basically
automatically discovers those laws of
boolean algebra that you know we needed
to know previously so it discovers you
know the definition of implication is
covers double negation elimination the
Morgan laws so I think this prequel okay
all right so now that we have seen that
it can do this you know slightly
non-trivial piece of programming how can
we use the synthesis technology to
actually build real software right so
because they aren't going to show you
before in this graph they were all
textbook algorithms we already know them
you know can we actually use it to
synthesize something useful well you
might be thinking since I showed you how
well this works that in five years or so
software development will be like this
so I stood on my couch and I say let
there be Instagram and then Instagram
comes out well unfortunately possibly
and so these techniques still don't
scale although well and also expressing
a specification for what you know for
the whole Instagram might be pretty
challenging right so in this part of the
talk I'll sort of tell you what I think
the most compelling and promising
applications for this technology are you
know as it relates to real software
development and in fact I think we're
synthesis can help us the most is in
dealing with orthogonal concerns or our
toggling requirements or cross-cutting
concerns so when you're developing a
software system there are many different
requirements that you have to keep in
mind right so you might be worried about
functional requirements that relate
input an output of your system you might
be worried about some dating we're
answering to maintain some security
policies that you have to enforce or
maybe some resource constraint in so
today programmer has to worry about all
of these things at the same time and
sort of integrate them all together into
the code base and so if one of the worst
things about that is that if one of the
requirements changes then you have to
basically go through the whole code and
figure out what will you have to change
so one of the strong points of
specifications is in fact that
they are really good for composing
cross-cutting concerns so if you if you
have specifications in your language
that you then you might be able to
simply think about your functional
requirements first formalize them as a
specification then think about your
daily - then think about a security
formalize each one of them separately as
a specification and then have your
compiler have your synthesis aided
language take care of integrating them
all together into your codebase so let
me give you just a taste of what you
know since this aided programming of the
future might look like but just giving
you a couple of examples of work that
I've been doing you know Rick more
recently the extension to exceptions to
sync way that we've been working on
recently so one of them will be in the
domain of security so today many
software systems manipulate sensitive
data in non-trivial ways right and each
piece of information that a user puts
into the system might be subject to some
complex custom confidentiality policies
but govern which other users may or may
not see this piece of data under which
circumstances and traditionally to
implement these policies programmers
would sprinkle this policy check
throughout their copies that would test
for a particular value whether a user is
allowed to see it or not right and the
problem with this approach is that well
it's very error-prone and in fact
getting any of those checks wrong can
cause an information leak right and this
in fact happens all the time so remember
just last year journalist Ashley
Feinberg was able to discover secret
Twitter and Instagram accounts of the
former FBI director James Comey right
then how did she discover that well she
followed commis son
call me on Instagram I believe and then
she got a recommendation why don't you
want to follow this you know
suspicious-looking account and this is
how she discovered it so basically what
happened is that Instagram leaked this
secret information which is the follows
relation of a private account and it
makes it like in this non-trivial way
through a recommendation system right so
these things are hard to get right
so to help programmers enforce
information process we developed this
little synthesis aided language called
lifti on top of sync with and in lifti
you can write your program like a normal
functional language without worrying
about security is if all the data were
public and then on the side you can
specify all the security policies in one
place and then lift it would go in and
insert all this little required policy
checks throughout your code and we'll
give you a provable guarantee that you
can system now satisfies your policies
another example is just like really
working progress that I'm doing with one
of my students and it's in the domain of
resource constraints so why would you
care about resource constraints and
there are many reasons to care about
them but one of them is also has to do
with security actually it's called
timing attacks so imagine that you're
implementing this function that compares
to lists for length it tries to figure
out whether the length is the same so if
you like the most normal implementation
of this function we'll go through the
list and stop at the point where the
shortest list ends right and then say
nope they're not equal but in fact if
one of the lists turns out to be secret
right this algorithm is actually no good
anymore because it stops at the shortest
list it actually the execution time all
this algorithm reveals the length of the
shortest list right and an attacker who
to learn the length of your password can
like pass it really long a tenth and the
measure of the execution time of this
function to figure out what the length
of the password is so and this is called
timing attacks and in particular and
more generally side-channel attacks okay
so how can synthesis aided programming
well so we developed this little
resource aware sort of language called
resin so in the first place it's built
on top of cigarettes so if you want to
implement this function in the first
place it's already much more concise
because you can simply specify it like
this it takes in two lists and it
returns a boolean that is equal to you
know whether the length of the two lists
is equal but it was more impressively if
you learn that one of those lists is
private and you're not supposed to
reveal its length the only change that
you need to make to this program is
change the type of the list element in
the second case so what this type means
is that well in this list each element
is given a unit of resource and then our
type system enforces that you use
precisely all the resources that you
have no more no less and then as a
result so it's sort of you can imagine
that one unit of resource is allocated
to every element in your attempt list
and it goes through you're consuming
those resources and you basically your
algorithm has to you know consume all
the resources and basically by making
this little change you know all of a
sudden sync we would generate a move
different code that is actually will
iterate until the length of the public
list as opposed to until the end of the
first list okay so this is my sort of
fission that you have you know synthesis
alien languages in which you you can
express every piece of sort of
requirements in the most suitable
notation some of them you might just
write in traditional programming
language and some of them you would
express with different kinds of
specification that are you know the most
natural for this requirement so this is
basically it please play with
synchronous it's available online and
thank you for listening
[Applause]